er tötete eiskalt und gnadenlos anders
breivik ermordete 77 menschen in nur
drei stunden um uns herum sei es grausam
aus
verwundete kinder es langte um uns herum
die zum glück abgedeckt waren
ich habe menschen gesehen die geblutet
haben überall war chaos
wer ist der mensch der jahrelang diesem
feldzug des todes planten wird sein
kampfgeist wie er ihn nannte schwach war
dass er sich nazi musik anstellte und
raus in den wald lief um sich selbst zu
motivieren um den richtigen kampfmodus
zurückzukriegen breiviks menschenjagd
auf utoya endet in einem massaker
nur wer glück hatte konnte fliehen
einige der kugeln gegen ins wasser
andere trafen das boot
wir erzählen die geschichte der
überlebenden und der angehörigen der
opfer an der rezeption lagen listen aus
mit den namen derjenigen die überlebt
hatten
aber wir konnten ihren namen nicht
finden
doch wie wurde breivik wirklich gestoppt
wir rekonstruieren die operation der
delta einheit unser mann an der spitze
hat der big im visier und war bereit
brevik zu erschießen man hätte ihm in
den kopf geschossen
[Musik]
oslo zehn jahre nach dem mörderischen
feldzug des anders breivik
besonders schwer ist es für jene die an
diesem tag ihre liebsten verloren haben
oder selbst dem tod nur knapp entkommen
sind
lisbeth rheinland verlor ihre tochter
sinne miriam eingangs haug entging nur
knapp den kugeln des attentäters beide
frauen hat dieser schicksalstag
zusammengeführt lisbeth und miriam
leiten eine selbsthilfegruppe für die
überlebenden des mörderischen amoklaufs
und wie die anderen auch führen sie
einen verzweifelten kampf gegen das
vergessen gewonnen werden kann er nicht
ich als mutter erlebe viele düstere tage
gerade im ersten jahr war es schwer
ich brauchte eine lange zeit um zu
akzeptieren was passiert ist ich werde
es nie vergessen
ich vermisse sie und denke immer daran
wer sie heute wäre was sie machen würde
und alles andere
heute wäre so eine 28 jahre alt sie war
damals ein lebenslustiges junges mädchen
deren große leidenschaft die kunst und
fotografie war dann beendete anders
breivik ihr leben mit drei schüssen in
den kopf
miriam hingegen überlebte das massaker
nur mit viel glück
breivik schoss durch eine tür hinter der
sich die damals 16 jährige versteckte
die kugeln verfehlten sie knapp ich habe
meine jugend auf utoya verloren
ich war 16 und bin in dem jahr 17
geworden und meine jugend wurde mir
einfach genommen
an dem tag wurde ich erwachsen es ist
der 22
juli 2011 an dem ausflug zum
anschlagsziel fort um 15 uhr 15 als sich
anders breivik in einem weißen vw
transporter dem regierungsviertel nährt
im stauraum des wagens eine 950
kilogramm schwere selbst gebaute bombe
aus ammoniumnitrat und dieselöl um 15
uhr 17 hält eine überwachungskamera fest
wie breivik den wagen direkt vor dem
regierungsgebäude parkt und sich dann
entfernt
zehn minuten später wird es zur
katastrophe kommen und das ist erst der
anfang
als er die bombe scharf macht
ich weiß nicht mehr wie viele sekunden
er hatte aber er hat es getan
so hielt er konnte also nicht 100
prozent sicher sein dass sie nicht mit
ihm im auto hochgehen würde er sagte ich
war vorbereitet zu sterben
um 15.27 erschüttert eine gewaltige
explosion das regierungsviertel
die druckwelle ist gewaltig und
zerstörerisch mit seinem handy filmt ein
überlebender die dramatischen minuten
nach der explosion der beruft er immer
wieder nach verletzt
hallo
kaká
noch ist unklar wie viele opfer der
anschlag gefordert hat die straßen vor
dem regierungsgebäude gleichen einem
kriegsschauplatz auch das verlagsgebäude
der norwegischen tageszeitung verdens
gang ist stark beschädigt
zu diesem zeitpunkt sitzt der journalist
an dass die java in seinem büro im
dritten stock der reporter hat glück und
wird nicht verletzt er läuft sofort auf
die straße
ich habe menschen gesehen die geblutet
haben überall war chaos bis auf den
alarm war es gespenstisch ruhig und
verwüstet ich habe eine person gesehen
die glaube ich tot war
sie lag direkt vor dem regierungsgebäude
andere kümmerten sich um sie da war
dieser komischen geruch in der luft und
das ganze hat sich angefühlt als wären
wir ganz allein auf der welt acht
menschen sterben bei der explosion
dutzende werden verletzt
oslo versinkt im chaos während die
sicherheitsbehörden noch von einem
terroranschlag durch islamisten ausgehen
halten überwachungskameras fest wie der
attentäter in einen weiteren wagen
steigt sein eigentliches ziel hat er
noch vor sich
wie genau und minutiös der norweger
seine taten geplant hatte wird erst
später durch die umfangreichen
ermittlungen deutlich über einen
zeitraum von neun monaten wird breivik
nach seiner verhaftung von nummern hier
eine szene aus dem vernehmungsprotokoll
leiter des verhörteams
kriminalpsychologe asprion rechnet der
spezialist schafft es nahezu anders
breivik aufzubauen
sein ziel so präzise wie möglich die
motivation und seine vorbereitung zu
entschlüsseln
er sagte dass er norwegen beschützen
müsse vor der invasion
er müsse europa davor beschützen
das war seine motivation und angeblich
seinen grund warum er das tun musste er
hatte das gefühl dass europa angegriffen
würde
er hielt sich vereinen soldaten anders
breiviks sohn eines diplomaten act schon
in der schule an
der junge hat wenig freunde ist
verhaltensauffällig als jugendlicher
wird er mehrfach wegen sachbeschädigung
von der polizei aufgegriffen eine
freundin hat breivik nicht dafür
interessiert er sich für waffen und
rechtsradikale ideologien mit 20 beginnt
er seinen amoklauf zu entwickeln in
seinem größenwahn verfasst breisig jahre
später eine art testament 90 minuten vor
dem bombenanschlag in oslo verschickt er
ein 1500 seiten langes manuskript an
journalisten und politiker titel 2083
eine europäische
unabhängigkeitserklärung
3 weg sieht sich auf einem kreuzzug
gegen den islam und kommunismus
er wähnt sich in einem heiligen krieg
beschwört einen pan europäischen
faschismus
er posiert in fantasieuniformen und
zeigt sich kampfbereit als soldat mit
einem scharfschützengewehr
schließlich bejubelt er in seinem
pamphlet einen erfolgreichen sprengstoff
test mit den worten boom die explosion
war erfolgreich und wenn du dich zu
einem anschlag entschließt ist es besser
so viele wie möglich zu töten ansonsten
gefährdet du die ideologische
durchschlagskraft des angriffs am ende
schließt er ich glaube das wird mein
letzter eintrag sie diese wahnwelt
interagiert diesen ganzen abwehrkampf
wer sich dann aber auch kostümiert und
was er da halt alles an einem einen
popanz aufbaut das hat auch keine
historische grundlage dieser ganze
verkleidungs zirkus das ist eigentlich
eine moderne erscheinung dass er
sozusagen sich vorstellt er wäre
mitglied in einem geheimen orten in
einem templerorden da steckt also der
wunsch dahinter die welt zu beherrschen
oder spricht davon dass es eine
christliche al qaida geben müsste also
eine christliche terror-organisation
eine christliche organisation die sich
den mitteln von al qaida bedient aber
gleichzeitig die an fehler abstellen
müsse aber eben auf der an auf deren
modus operandi setzt also auf
terroranschläge und so weiter
nach dem anschlag in oslo setzte breivik
seinen blutigen terror zug fort sein
ziel das 40 kilometer entfernte utoya
er hat sich als polizist verkleidet und
trägt eine gefälschte dienstmarke das
eiland im tyrifjord ist gerade mal so
groß wie zehn fußballwetter die insel
ist ein beliebter ferienort zu diesem
zeitpunkt befinden sich hier mehr als
500 kinder und jugendliche im sommercamp
die meisten von ihnen gehören der af an
die jugendorganisation der
sozialistischen partei norwegens am tag
zuvor feierten die jugendlichen noch
ausgelassen auf einem karaoke auf
[Musik]
er sagte dass er sie weil sie mitglieder
der arbeiterpartei waren als feinde
einstufen musste da die partei
einwanderung erlaubt hat immigration und
weil sie mitglieder der arbeiterpartei
waren waren sie legitim
sie hatten seiner meinung nach norwegen
betrogen
auch miriam ist zu diesem zeitpunkt auf
der insel und genießt mit ihren freunden
die unbeschwerte zeit
[Musik]
wir hatten spaß und alles war normal
ich freute mich auf den herbst und auf
die neue schule auf die ich gehen würde
alles war einfach großartig
am nachmittag des 22 juli werden die
jugendlichen aus ihrer unbeschwertheit
herausgerissen
sie hören von dem bombenanschlag in oslo
von den toten und verletzten
doch hier auf der kleinen insel mitten
im fjord fühlen sie sich sicher auch
sünde die tochter von lisbeth ist im
camp als sie von den dramatischen
ereignissen erfährt ich musste ans ende
denken darum meldete ich mich bei ihr
sie hatte von dem anschlag gehört und
saß im cafeteria gebäude zusammen mit
den anderen jugendlichen aus oslo
hier ging es gut und sie machte sich
gedanken wie es uns gehen würde
zu diesem zeitpunkt befindet sich anders
breivik schon an der anlegestelle
gegenüber von utoya
es ist 16 55 häufig ist mit einer
pistole der marke glock und einem
halbautomatischen gewehr bewaffnet
ähnlich wie hier auf diesem foto
er gibt an als polizist die kinder auf
der insel schützen sowohl um 17 uhr 17
betritt bei viktoria und beginnt sofort
seinen mörderischen amoklauf hinter dem
haupthaus eröffnet er das feuer
er schießt camp leiterin monika böse
genannt nummer utoya und trond berntsen
polizist und der stiefbruder von
kronprinzessin mette marit
die erste exekution auf utoya
er erinnerte sich daran wie er seine
pistole auf der insel zum ersten mal
hoch und es sich für ihn anfühlte als
habe es eine halbe minute oder eine
ganze minute
obwohl es nur ein paar sekunden er
beschrieb es wie eine art zeitlupen
erfahrung aber dann nach ein paar tötung
automatisch
als die schüsse fallen denken die
jugendlichen zunächst an ein feuerwerk
betreuer andré steht keine 100 meter von
dem schützen entfernt
ich war in der hütte die damals hier
stand als ich gewehr vorher hörte ich
ging raus und ich sah wie menschen in
meine richtung flüchteten mir war klar
ich muss hier weg
ich lief da hinten da wo früher die
cafeteria streit in dem wald auf den
trampelpfad der um die integriert
während bei wind in den wald flüchtet
suchen andere jugendliche schützen der
cafeteria gegen 17 uhr 27 betritt anders
breivik mit vorgehaltener waffe das
holzhäuschen ruhig und präzise feuert er
auf die jungen camp-bewohner 13 von
ihnen sterben im kugelhagel
die einschusslöcher in den wänden
dokumentieren noch heute die grausamen -
blutiger feldzug dauert schon eine halbe
stunde
der schütze bewegt sich richtung ufer
hier verstecken sich die meisten
jugendlichen immer wieder hallen die
gewehrsalven bis ans festland anwohner
dokumentieren mit dem handy die
dramatischen minuten
die jugendlichen suchen schutz am ufer
oder versuchen verzweifelt auf die
andere seite zu schwimmen
[Musik]
auch bei wind will sich zusammen mit
zehn anderen campbewohner am ufer
verstecken doch sicher sind sich hier
nicht denn der schütze ist keine 100
meter von der gruppe entfernt
[Musik]
das war hier wie man sieht eine sehr
ungeschützte stelle
wir haben uns dann entschieden hier
wegzugehen und das war unser glück denn
der stein strand hier unten war einer
der letzten orte auf utoya an dem
menschen an diesem tag getötet wurden
auch miriam rennt um ihr leben
zusammen mit anderen jugendlichen läuft
sie zur inselschule hier will sich die
gruppe in sicherheit
wir waren dort glaube ich mit 40 50
personen wir versteckten uns und
verbarrikadierten die fenster und türen
und alles andere wir verschlossen die
tür und dann warteten wir wir hatten
schüsse und nach kurzer zeit schritte
die näher kam es in den raum das
geräusch war so laut dass ich dachte
jetzt werde ich erschossen
die zwei schüsse abfeuerte trafen nur
ein stück über meinen kopf ein
nur einen meter entfernt die geräusche
ist der telefone die klingelten waren so
laut dass wir sie ausschalten mussten
schickte meinen eltern also eine
nachricht und schrieb ihn dass ich sie
liebe
und dann musste ich mein handy
ausschalten und warten
die situation auf utoya wird immer
dramatischer 3 weg zündet zwei
rauchgranaten zu diesem zeitpunkt hat er
schon über 50 menschen erschossen ebenso
viele sind schwer verletzt die anwohner
filmen wie jugendliche versuchen sich in
einem ruderboot in sicherheit zu bringen
es ist mit seiner gruppe
und wenn bis zur häme
wohin wir haben gesehen wie er zum
wasser gegangen ist dann ging er auf den
steg hob seine waffe und zielte
wir haben uns zu boden geworfen und ich
habe den luftzug der ersten kugel
gespürt die direkt über meinen kopf
geflogen ist
nach mehreren schüssen auf eine frau
sein magazin leer
einige der kugeln gegen ins wasser
andere trafen das boot einige flogen
direkt über uns wir hatten glück weil er
keinen von uns im boot verletzt hatte 50
minuten schon kann anders breivik
ungehindert seine tötungsfantasien in
die tat umsetzen
gäste eines campingplatzes retten mit
ihren boten die flüchtenden camp
bewohner aus dem wasser um 18 09 treffen
einheiten der anti terror gruppe delta 1
die norwegischen elitepolizisten
spezialisiert auf geiselbefreiung haben
so gut wie keine information über die
lage auf der insel
der damalige leiter des kommandos an das
wort heinz müller
das delta team hatte sich an diesem tag
auf einer übung nahe oslo befunden
aber deshalb schnell einsatzbereit mit
22 mann besteigen sie drei boote die
einheit rechnet mit mehreren attentätern
und konnte vom schiff aus die schüsse
hören
meine männer waren nicht mit der gegend
vertraut der hafen war die einzige
sichere stelle für die boote die
ausrüstung die sie bei sich trugen
bestand aus pistolen maschinenpistolen
von heckler koch und sie hatten
scharfschützen gewähre
wir haben uns auf eine sehr komplizierte
situation eingestellt
meine männer haben miteinander
gesprochen und sich darauf vorbereitet
sie wussten heute ist der tag an dem wir
alles geben müssen
um 18.25 landet die erste delta einheit
auf der insel
sie bewegt sich schnell in richtung
schüsse eine gruppe jugendlicher sucht
hinter einer mauer schutz
die zweite einheit bewegt sich entlang
der küste er bietet sich ein
schrecklicher anblick am ufer liegen die
leblosen körper der jugendlichen
[Musik]
selbst an der abgelegenen pumpstation
konnten die flüchtenden keinen schutz
finden viele der jugendlichen haben
versucht sich hinter der kleinen punkt
station zu verstecken
in diesem bereich waren viele von ihnen
sie hatten aber keine chance wegzulaufen
als breivik hierhin kam erschoss er jede
um displays hawk i believe the numbers
die immense zahl war kaum zu glauben
weil männer haben mir später gesagt dass
sie hofften dass es aufhören würde weil
sie immer mehr opfer auf der insel die
elite polizisten durchforsten die insel
meter für meter
immer wieder fallen schüsse um 18 33
erreicht die einheit die schule in der
sich miriam mit ihrer gruppe
verbarrikadiert hat drei weg ist noch
ganz in der nähe in diesem bereich wo
sie mehrere schüsse gehört und einige
bewegungen dort hinten zwischen den
bäumen wahrgenommen und sind dann sofort
in diese richtung vorgestoßen
der amokläufer steht den einheiten 30
meter entfernt gegenüber sein gewehr im
anschlag
als breivik hier in dieser position
stand schrie mein team ihn an und befahl
ihm sofort stehen zu bleiben
die arme zu heben und aufzugeben und
dann hat er eine bewegung nach rechts
gemacht und sein gewehr hier an den baum
gestellt und er kam ihnen ganz ruhig
entgegen
die hände nach unten sie waren sich
sicher dass er eine sprengstoffweste tot
also wollte sie nicht dass er ihnen noch
näher kommt unser mann in der spitze
hatte breivik im visier und war bereit
brevik zu erschießen
er hatte vorher einen punkt festgelegt
wurde brevik diesen überschreiten gebe
es keinen weg zurück
stopp trick stoppte in dieser position
er war also nur einen schritt davon
entfernt getötet zu werden
man hätte ihm in den kopf geschossen
nach 74 minuten kann um 18 35 breiviks
gnadenloser amoklauf gestoppt werden
die punkte auf der karte markieren die
stellen an denen die menschen ihr leben
verloren haben
am ende zählt die polizei 69 tot
der gelbe punkt zeigt den ort der
festnahme des amokläufers breivik wird
fixiert und ins haupthaus der insel
überführt dort beginnt die erste
befragung der mann der noch vor minuten
wie im todesrad gemordet hatte sitzt
jetzt regungslos in einem stuhl und
jammert
[Musik]
er war ruhig und hat sich über eine
verletzung an seinem finger beschwert
der mann der ihn hier in gewahrsam
genommen hatte sagte sag mal vorüber
redest du eigentlich
du hast dich hier über gar nichts zu
beschweren halt einfach die klappe
komplett ab um 18.45 treffen die ersten
rettungskräfte auf der insel ein
die ärzte und sanitäter haben
schwierigkeiten die schwer verletzten
jugendlichen zu versorgen
es sind einfach zu viele
es beginnt ein kampf um leben und tod
auch miriam gehört zu den überlebenden
sie ist nicht verletzt aber sie steht
sichtbar unter schock alles ging so
schnell wie ging runter zum boot und um
uns herum sei es grausam aus verwundete
kinder
es lagen tote um uns herum die zum glück
abgedeckt waren
[Musik]
alles um uns herum war so grausam es gab
vieles was man verarbeiten musste in
oslo verfolgt lisbeth am radio die
dramatischen ereignisse auf die tour sie
macht sich schreckliche sorgen seit
stunden hat sie von ihrer tochter sinne
nichts gehört
ich schrieb ihr aber sie antwortete
nicht
ich habe den ganzen abend versucht sie
anzurufen aber sie hob nicht ab
wir fuhren also mit dem auto los und als
wir dort ankamen
ich erinnere mich noch war es sehr
chaotisch wir liefen ins hotel und
suchten nach singen
ich dachte ich könnte sie einfach mit
nach hause nehmen
an der rezeption lagen listen aus mit
den namen derjenigen die überlebt hatten
aber wir konnten ihren namen nicht
finden
gelassen es rückwärts und wieder
vorwärts und jeden namen immer und immer
wieder
aber ihrer stand nicht drauf nach drei
tagen dann die gewissheit
die polizei bestätigt den tod von sonne
breivik hatte er dreimal in den kopf
geschossen
eine nation steht unter schock und die
welt trauert mit norwegen 77 menschen
verloren ihr leben weil ein wahnsinniger
seine mörderische fantasien in die tat
umsetzte bild ist zu diesem zeitpunkt
mit mehreren teams vor ort und berichtet
über die ereignisse
julian reiche damals chefreporter hier
vorjahr erlebt ein land das gebrochen
ist diese form von terrorismus wie sie
sich da in norwegen zugetragen hat die
hat ja in den in den köpfen von menschen
vorher nicht existiert dass es eine
rassen waren völkischen terrorismus
geben könnte der sich gegen kinder
richtet das bild team macht sich auf den
weg nach utoya hier sichern die
einsatzkräfte und ermittler nur spuren
versuchen den tathergang zu
rekonstruieren
inzwischen sind auch alle leichen
geborgen jetzt sollen sie zur
rechtsmedizin gebracht werden ich sah
auf einmal unten auf der straße uns
hingegen kommen einen leichenwagen und
nach anderthalb minuten sahen wir eine
prozession soweit man gucken konnte von
leichenwagen ich weiß nicht wie viele es
waren und man konnte in die wagen
teilweise ein einsehen und und sehen
dass
es gar nicht mehr genügend sage gab für
alle die ermordeten kinder sondern dass
die in leichensäcken in diesen in diesen
wagen lagen teilweise mehrere und das
war der moment in dem mir wird das
ausmaß dieser tat das erste mal
tatsächlich bewusst geworden ist das ist
aber bis heute für mich ein bild das
durchaus vergleichbar ist mit 9 11
am 25 juli drei tage nach dem
bombenattentat und dem massaker auf
utoya wird anders breivik dem
haftrichter im osloer stadtgericht
vorgeführt dort gesteht er die taten
plädiert aber auf nicht schuldig im
polizeipräsidium von oslo wird breivik
vernommen asprion rach lew und sein
sechsköpfiges team führen die befragung
durch
jetzt gilt es einen der schlimmsten
massenmörder zu knacken
insgesamt 31 mal werden sie ihn verhören
neun monate 220 stunden lang und anders
breivik gibt bereitwillig einblick in
seine verstörende gedanken er war sehr
gut vorbereitet auch physisch er war
sehr fit als der tag kam er sagte uns
sogar 80 kilo revolte nicht 78 auch weil
er dann zu schwach gewesen wäre auch
nicht 82 kilo weil er dann zu langsam
er sagt mein kampfgewicht nach und nach
ergeben die ermittlungen wie minutiös
breiviks seinem blutigen kreuzzug
geplant hatte auf einer angemieteten
farm bei asta 170 kilometer nördlich von
oslo hatte er sich als gemüsebauer getan
so konnte er sich unbemerkt auf die tat
vorbereiten
bei der durchsuchung finden ermittler
die reste von insgesamt sechs tonnen
düngemittel das er zuvor im internet
bestellt hatte in der vernehmung
schilderte genau wie er sich in der
ländlichen abgeschiedenheit mental auf
seinen tag iks vorbereitet es gab zeiten
wenn sein kampfgeist wie er ihn nannte
schwach war es so dass er sich nazi
musik anstellte und raus in den wald
lief um sich selbst zu motivieren um den
richtigen kampfmodus zurückzukriegen
hier so based all seine aktionen
basierten auf dem glauben dass sich
europa im krieg befand am 16 april 2012
knapp neun monate nach der tat wird
anders breivik unter höchsten
sicherheitsvorkehrungen in oslo vor
gericht gestellt
der massenmörder lächelt als er in den
gerichtssaal geführt wird
im zuschauerraum die angehörigen der
opfer
breivik genießt den auftritt keine fünf
meter von dem amokläufer entfernt
verfolgt bild reporter kai feldhaus den
prozess
auf der anderen seite in dem zuschauer
brauche ich saßen dutzende von eltern
die ihre kinder verloren hatten
tränenüberströmte handwerker frauen die
sich an den taschentüchern festhalten
während im auf dem zeugenstuhl halbe
kinder jugendliche saßen die teilweise
sichtbar von schüssen von breivik
verletzt waren also die augen verloren
hatten narben im gesicht ich erinnere
mich an ein mädchen das ein teil des t
shirts hob und man konnte darunter noch
die die ein schusswunden sehen die
vernarbten und er sitzt einfach und
grinst vor sich hin
der massenmörder nutzt die verhandlung
als bühne mal zeigt er den hitlergruß
ein anderes mal weint er vor rührung
über seine zeilen aus dem manifest nur
eines zeit breivik nicht heuer es ist
die verstörende vorstellung eines
psychopathen am 24 august wird anders
breivik wegen mordes an 77 menschen zu
21 jahren mit anschließender
sicherungsverwahrung verurteilt wieder
lächelt er nach dem urteil hebt breivik
seine rechte faust und schwafelt dass er
das gericht nicht anerkenne
also auch nicht das urteil dann wird er
abgeführt und in das
hochsicherheitsgefängnis von ila bei
oslo verbracht hatten unsere arbeit
beendet und der prozess war vorüber aber
etwas hatte sich in uns aufgeschlossen
plötzlich merkte ich dass etwas mit mir
passierte und ich habe einfach
angefangen zu weinen
der raum war voll mit polizisten und es
fühlte sich sehr sehr gut an
wie oft miriam in den letzten jahren
geweint hat darüber will sie nicht
sprechen so oft es geht besucht sie das
mahnmal in der osloer innenstadt das an
die opfer der anschläge erinnert den
namen breivik will sie nicht mehr
aussprechen
[Musik]
er verkörpert das schlimmste was mir je
passiert ist er hat meine freunde
umgebracht aber ich denke in meinem
alltag nicht an ihn auch liesbeth kämpft
jeden tag mit den erinnerungen und dem
schmerz ihre tochter söhne verloren zu
haben
[Musik]
ich werde nie über ihren tod hinweg
kommen aber man lernt damit zu leben
insofern dass ich sozusagen mein neues
leben begonnen habe und ich muss mich
auch um den rest meiner familie kümmern
ich würde gerade großmutter geworden und
das ist schön
sie wird immer bei uns sein bei der
ganzen familie
einmal im jahr treffen sie sich in oslo
und auf utoya die angehörigen denen
breivik alles genommen hat 77 menschen
ermordet an einem sommertag am 22 juli